oh this is a big one yes it's funny
because you've been off the grid and me
being me I feel like all of these sound
like I'm trolling you and I'm not uh-oh
so someone did some research uh um
in Obama's history you know him's
writing his autobiographies which are
very much mythological and trying to
create a narrative about who he was and
and they found letters that had been
suppressed where he was writing to his
ex-girlfriend at the time about how he
fantasizes daily about having sex with
men
wow so now you guys have something in
common
end the stream
wait wow well this has been rumored this
has been oh that's funny this has been
rumored for a long time right I mean
remember that there was that video of
like the gay prostitute right from when
Obama was running the first time so this
is what
2007. well if Barack Obama had a son he
would look like Andrew Gillum that's
funny uh so so wow and our so this is
verified that this is legit I mean the
letters of error the letters are
verified he hasn't addressed it yeah
this is the point I made on Twitter and
I think it's
actually it's funny but I think it's
true for a long time there was this uh
Mystique about political figures yeah
and Bill Clinton was never asked about
the pretty uh um
grounded rape accusations from Juanita
Broderick yeah and that dam broke I
think it was either I think it was in
2020 that that a reporter actually asked
him to his face and this was kind of
under the radar but to me it was a huge
moment that now instead of protecting oh
we can't ask him about this right right
no we're going to ask him at some point
I predict and this isn't a big
prediction someone is going to ask
former president Barack Obama did you
stop having gay fantasies after you got
married right Michelle Obama and when
that happens it's going to be the
funniest thing on earth so basically
you're saying and I and I think I've
roughly been making this argument the
protection racket that the media used to
have right before the politicians he's
coming to an end yes there was a
constant protection racket where they
could distract you and keep you thinking
about something else you know who really
broke it it was even before 2020 with
Juanita it was Trump in 2016 when he
took all of Bill Clinton's accusers to
the debate remember like it was
Stuttering John when he asked Jennifer
Flowers if oh God sleep with any other
presidential candidates and Bill Clinton
used the condom so that was in about 90
a little bit more about this so did
anyone care like was it or is it it's
the thing is so what maybe he's gay not
that there's anything wrong with that
like I don't really care but it's like
Jesus please like this is an
intervention I know what you've been
doing it was my super and when I lived
in New York City
um but like not that anyone really cares
but you know people people do say
Michelle is uh Joan Rivers you know yeah
Joan River said that then she died but
no I think it's not that people really
cared it's good to be back it's not to
carry so much about the gay stuff but it
just speaks into the phoniness yes
because he always had this air and
people the the corporate press loved him
because he's every journalist what dream
they could read things into him and he's
yeah I'm just like you and you uh and
now it's kind of like this guy's kind of
a bit of a fraud did you see that
interview it was one of the last things
that we showed right before I left where
he's sitting down with some guy on
Central or something and they're asking
him because he wrote this like top 10
songs of the year and top 10 books that
he read and all this and the guy asked
him so come on you listen to these songs
he's like tell me one lyric from the
song and Obama gets all like oh come on
don't make me do that you know what
really yeah and it's like wow so
was called and that's exactly
what you're talking about if I ask you
like what's your favorite book and I'm
like name what's your scene oh I like
this moment no he literally that's what
he was doing it was like it was like
tell me what tell me what's that book
about what's that song about and Obama's
like are you gonna play me like that you
know wow so the thing is breaking
beautiful beautiful foreign